[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you very much all right
our band's going to play five seconds of
an original holiday song they wrote and
you have to name the very well-known and
expensive song it kind of sounds like
but is not and we can prove it
all right i am looking for jim
blaricum jim blaricum where are you oh
how conveniently located how are you jim
nice to see you too
how are you pal good
where are you from jim brooklyn you're
from brooklyn yeah you came a long way
just to see this show just to see the
show no other plans not doing anything
else nope flying in seeing this show and
leaving immediately yeah
playing in one hour okay uh fantastic
and i love the fact that you have a
beard and so does your clearly
bootlegged e.t it's mystery too well
that's mystery mr e.t
i
i love this guy
i love the people that come and see me
live
all right here's your clue you got you
ready for this all right
jim
if we tried to play this holiday classic
about a magical snowman we'd receive a
frosty visit
from the songwriter's lawyer
guys
[Music]
jim
what famous holiday song did that sort
of sound like
but definitely wasn't
frosty the snowman all right
yes jim yes
that might
that might have reminded you of frosty
the snowman but i assure you it was our
own 100
original holiday song coldy the slush
guy
and here to sing it is a man whose music
has achieved international success in
the torturing of north korean political
prisoners
a horrible entertainer i hate this guy
mr brian lafontaine brian
it was a silly silly chap with a yam
cigar and a velcro snazz and a bunch of
frozen crabs
awful he's an awful
awful performer um i'm spending
christmas alone in my mitsubishi gallant
yes
he's a lonely talentless creep uh
andy why don't you tell jim uh what he's
won
he's won a special new year's resolution
gym membership after 10 days it
automatically turns into a taco bell
congratulations nice to meet you too
cheers good man
i'm looking for caitlyn kameski caitlyn
oh
back here yeah
hi
how are you
thank you for being here kate you're
very beautiful thanks for being here on
the show yeah thank you
i didn't hope i didn't come across as
creepy i was just horribly offensive
paying you a compliment you're quite
attractive person um kaitlyn
where are you from dallas texas dallas
texas all the way from dallas just to
see the show and then leaving
immediately right immediately not
visiting family or friends i wouldn't
dream of it incredible
the devotion of these people
all right caitlin are you ready to play
okay i'm gonna just feed off your
enthusiasm
caitlyn
if we tried to get away with playing
what is generally considered the most
popular and only hanukkah song
we'd be sued by the law firm of dreidel
dreidel and dreidel
guys
[Music]
caitlin what holiday song would most
people claim we just ripped off dreidel
dreidel dreidel yes all right dreidel
song yes
okay well that may have sounded
[Music]
that may have sounded like the dreidel
song but i will insist in a court of law
it was our brand new hanukkah tune the
jewish top song
oh jewish top jewish top jewish love my
friend taught me how to play
but i got bored immediately and
pretended
you're the worst you're the absolute
worst i'm on probation for exposing
myself into starbucks yes
[Applause]
i don't know why he feels the need to
add these little gems
but he does andy would you tell caitlyn
what she's won
perfect for any girl girls bedroom wall
this cool poster featuring our props
department
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
cherish that for the rest of your life
nice to meet you thank you very much all
right
nassim
mahrani nasim bharani we're oh nasim
barani okay here we go right down here
never had to move this much that thing
almost hit my crotch hi
how are you
nice to see you
oh okay
let's just call this segment conan pervs
out with the crowd
uh where are you from woodland hills
woodland hills i don't know much i've
lived here for three years i still don't
know where anything is where is woodland
hills not far it's like 20 minutes away
nothing's 20 minutes away in l.a
what you mean is it's 45 minutes away
there's no such thing everyone says it's
20 minutes it's not 20 minutes
we like to think that it'll be 20
minutes and are you a student are you a
student where do you go to school pierce
college oh very good what are you
studying psychology okay maybe you could
help me after the show i can't
i'm not kidding uh
now seeing if we tried to play this
spanish-language holiday song by jose
feliciano
he would sue so hard would wish
we were felice navi dead
[Music]
okay
what holiday song will i swear in a
court we did not just rip off police
[Applause]
[Music]
you might think it's felice navidad but
i assure you it was our own spanish
holiday song
lorenzo llamas
lorenzo lamas
lorenzo lamas
just awful
i can't come within 50 yards of reese
witherspoon
just a little too thank you pal
i don't know why we have you back every
time i work cheap
oh yes uh
do me a favor andy and tell the lovely
nassim what she has won
it's this set of faces of meth holiday
ornaments
[Music]
wow
merry christmas
merry christmas you make sure you put
that up okay